Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm live.
Whoa, no intro.
I'm going in raw.
Let's go.
I don't think this kid didn't hear that.
They heard it in other people's chat, but not mine.
Wait, where's my... where's the code I posted?
Oh my god.
I'm actually... I am a Death Note fanatic.
I love Death Note so much.
I...
I bought everything.
I bought the novels.
I watched the live action movies.
The bad ones and the good ones.
I watched L Change the World.
That shit was terrible, but I still watched it.
I watched where he fucking solves a disease that's like COVID, but like it was pre-COVID when that movie came out.
And it was like, he like saves the world by curing COVID.
It was crazy.
And it was pre... it was literally pre-COVID when that movie came out.
And then I bought the Beyond Birthday stuff.
I bought like the art.
I was... I was a freak.
I was a fucking freak.
It was like my first... it was literally my first anime.
Like I... I did not care about anime until I found out about Death Note.
Who the fuck is Laddy 2?
Oh no.
Uh-oh.
Wait, did somebody show the code?
Did somebody show the code?
Who's... oh, okay.
We leave.
How do I leave?
Oh.
Okay.
I'll... I'll leave.
I... I quit.
Oh, it's Steam Maintenance.
No!
No, the thing is, guys.
It was...
The thing is, like, I'm unable... I'm unable to make it a private lobby because the code doesn't work in a private lobby.
I...
I was like, no, it's a pub.
Like, I was like, no, it's a fucking public lobby.
And I'm like, oh!
I get to actually invite... I can't even close the lobby.
That was the worst part.
I'm remaking the lobby now.
Oh, my God.
I literally... I quit!
I quit!
I have... Okay, I'm gonna make it private in the... I have to up... I need... I need... Guys, I need people to accept my friend request because a private lobby, you can't join via code.
You need to join via...
Oh, my God.
Anyway, this is Death Note Among Us.
Yeah, I'm waiting for Steam to come back up.
Why do I always accidentally make a collabs on Tuesday?
What's wrong with me?
It's like...
Okay, so... So, for those who don't know, this is basically like...
This is, like I said, it's Among Us.
It's basically Among Us, Death Note.
I'm just explaining the rules to my chat while we wait for it to come back.
I'm pretty sure... I'm pretty sure it was stream snipers.
I'm pretty sure... I'm pretty sure it was stream snipers that joined because Mint and I... Mint, Amelie, Grim and I, we were in that public lobby for so long.
And then suddenly, we all went live.
And then we all went live and then people were joining.
Randoms were joining our lobby.
So, I'm pretty sure it was a stream snipers that came in.
Like, I won't not be surprised.
Like, we were literally by ourselves in that lobby for so long.
We were there for so long just talking.
And then suddenly, like, seven people joined at once or somebody leaked the code.
It was that or somebody leaked the code.
So, I was like, what the fuck?
Like, how did all you guys get in?
Like, so fast.
Um, okay.
Connection failed.
Usually, it shouldn't be that bad.
I need to use the bathroom.
I was prepping for this collab.
I'll be right back real quick, guys.
Back.
I'm back.
Basically, okay.
So, this game is basically like, like I said, it's among us.
But instead of one imposter, there's five imposters.
But all the imposters are pretending that they are an investigator.
So, what's going on is that there's one Kira, one Elle, four Kira followers, and four investigators.
So, the investigators and Elle have to work together to figure out who is Kira.
And the game ends whether they all complete the... It's Kira versus Elle.
And they all have to complete tasks.
And it's either which team completes the most tasks or Elle dies or Kira dies.
So, it's one or the other.
So, or not Elle.
Elle dies or Kira gets arrested.
And when you get arrested, you're chained to a person.
So, it's like the famous handcuff stuff.
And you can, as Kira, you can actually give your notebooks to other followers.
So, if you think you're too sus, you can give your notebook to another Kira follower.
And then they become Kira.
So, there's a lot of mind games to it.
And then, like, you know, if Kira doesn't have... And then, like, when you arrest, when you call somebody out as sus... Okay, let me hide this.
When you call somebody else as sus, you have to give... They're going to hold items.
But you can accidentally give the items to a Kira follower.
So, if a Kira... If you think a Kira follower is investigated, like they tricked you and they're called out too much, that might be Kira, won't get in trouble.
So, like, they'll still continue the game.
Because, like, a Kira follower grabs... Got all the items and stuff.
So, it's, like, very...
It's very interesting.
Okay, let's see.
I'm creating the room right now.
Okay, not to actually...
Alright, now!
Now it's private.
I did it!
Okay, now I need to...
Alright, now I gotta add people.
I'm adding people right now.
Okay, we got... And then, I need to make sure...
Wait, not everybody is on.
I need everybody to get on.
Oh my god.
Okay, here we go.
Get on Discord.
I mean, get on Steam.
I mean, get online so I can...
Alright.
Okay, I'm waiting for... I'm waiting for people to get on Steam so I can...
People are slowly logging in.
Oh, have mercy.
Okay, have mercy.
I don't see it yet.
Somebody is... Why is Bao playing web fishing?
What?
Why is Bao playing web fishing?
I noticed Bao is not on the right game right now.
Okay, the people... I still have no friends.
I still have no friends.
Okay, I'm inviting people, but why no people join me?
Cute.
Please show up online so I can invite you.
I'm sending invites now.
I'm sending invites.
Why is nobody getting on?
Why am I alone?
I'm sending so many invites.
Oh wait, there's Minh.
Okay, and then there's Bao.
There's Vienna.
Oh, you might have to restart.
Damn, I have to restart Steam because I got in automatically.
Maybe restart Steam.
It's not the game.
It's Steam.
I'm by myself.
I'm alone in this world.
I'm alone.
Lonely.
Mr. Lonely.
I have nobody.
I'm ready to call my own.
Okay, all right, I need a re-invite.
Okay, it's re-invite invitation time.
The hardest part, getting 10 people in the lobby.
I think that's actually the hardest part.
Getting 10 people into this lobby.
Oh my god.
Okay, invite.
Invite.
Uh, invite.
Um, I'm losing.
Um, there's too many people.
Invite.
Uh, did I invite this person?
I think I did.
Okay, and then I'm just waiting for people to just send some more invites again.
Okay, all right, this should work.
I didn't get one.
Oh my god, do I have to get online?
God fucking...
No, I can't be invisible.
I have to pretend to be online again.
I have to.
Okay, give me a sec.
All right, preferences.
Privacy settings.
No, I have to pretend I'm... I exist on the... I pretend I exist.
All right, friends menu.
Queue.
I have to pretend I exist on Steam again.
God fucking damn it.
Okay, this should work now.
This should work.
Okay.
Uh, oh my god, I hope I don't accidentally invite the wrong people.
Okay, did it work now?
No!
Okay, do I need to... I need to restart Steam!
Okay, I restart Steam.
Okay, oh my god, okay, I restart Steam.
Okay, oh my god, guys, Steam.
This is just...
This is a Steam issue, I would like to say.
It is not, um, it's not, um... Wait, maybe... Okay, wait.
It is a Steam issue, chat.
It is nothing else.
It is merely a Steam issue.
It is not a Doki issue.
All right, back at it again.
Back to Death Note Killer Within.
It's just unlucky that we had the...
That we have maintenance that messed everything up.
And I choose, like, I always accidentally choose the time, too.
I keep forgetting.
I keep forgetting Tuesday is, like, a fucking actual day.
Like, it's just... Oh, I keep forgetting that Tuesday exists.
Tuesday at 3 p.m.
every time.
Because I'm like, oh, I should get a time for that work for, like, our EU person.
Like, we should, we should have that.
And then I'm like, oh my god.
Oh my god.
But every time.
Every time.
Wait, does it work now?
Does it work now?
And invites are still weird.
Because maybe someone else should make lobby.
Maybe I shouldn't make lobby.
Steam won't start.
We're all having problems.
Oh!
Oh, it's not.
It's not me.
I knew it.
I knew it's not me.
It's not me.
I knew I wasn't the issue.
Wait, you're different now.
We did it!
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm gonna start inviting more people.
All right.
Oh my god, it's working.
It's working.
It wasn't me.
I knew it.
I knew I wasn't the problem.
I fucking knew it, guys.
Never think you're the problem.
Never.
Okay, let's see.
Who else?
All right, I don't think I...
It's V.
Yeah, yeah.
If you want to... Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, oh, you go to settings and then you go to... it's at this audio.
I'm gonna turn that off, too.
Hello?
I have proximity chat.
Yeah, yeah.
Hey, we got you.
Hello!
Okay, I'm turning up.
Oh my god!
Pay to win!
Let's go!
Okay, like, can you guys invite people or only... only I can... is it only I can invite people or can you guys invite people, too?
Uh, let me see.
Because it's in the... Is there a way to make it push to talk instead of... Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You go to settings and you click sound.
I'm on... I'm not on push to talk right now because we're setting up.
Okay, I'll up the game a little bit.
Uh, oh my gosh.
Oh, there you go!
We got Limu!
Oh my god, we got L!
Okay, Limu is definitely an L.
Fucking nerd.
Okay, we good.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Hey, I'm L.
Oh, you're not.
You're like... I joined the fucking game and I get called a fucking nerd.
Okay, okay, I'm gonna show guys.
This is...
This is a dollar store L right here.
Guess who's like... This is like bootleg L, right?
I'm literally L!
It's on my shirt!
It's literally on my t-shirt!
You're not okay, L.
What happened?
You look like... You look like you took like a soccer ball to the face, like...
No, I look like I got stung by like some bees.
Oh, yeah, you got like those like dogs.
Those dogs that got stung by like bees and stuff.
Yeah, yeah.
That looks like you.
Okay, let me see who else I have.
Oh, we got... It's kind of like if L started aging and then got into denial and just got way too much Botox over it.
Alright, let me check my settings.
You got like... Oh my god, you went to the wrong plastic surgeon, that's for sure.
Yeah.
Okay, I'm gonna boost up.
Let's see.
Question, would this game not let anybody else have like... It wouldn't let me use the name Monarch.
I don't know.
I was like, you're not allowed to use that name, and I went, huh?
That's weird.
Weird.
Yeah, it's weird.
Yeah, I have like, uh...
I don't know.
Maybe... I don't know if like... I think these names... Maybe somebody else already named themselves Monarch.
I think these names are like...
Claimed.
You can claim names here.
Oh, I think... I think so too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So there's actual usernames here.
Honestly, some of these avatars look like dolls in like a Chucky movie or something.
No, they're like the...
They're like puppets from N.
He uses these puppets.
They're really ugly, but like...
I see.
Ugly.
But he's an orphan, so like, it's excused.
Wait, who made these?
N, Nier.
The two kids.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, the L successor.
The little guy.
The blonde one, right?
No, that's Mellow.
Oh.
That's Mellow.
It's like the ones that people care less about when they jump the shark.
Wait, so he's the white haired one?
Yeah, he's the white haired one.
Oh my god, you gotta get your Weeb card revoked.
I really um actually do an anime lore.
That's so sad.
Look, I just got stung by 10,000 bees, okay?
I'm crazy.
You let me um actually do.
You just got out of the ER.
Yeah, I'm, I'm going through it, okay?
Did the doctors give you that little like party thing?
Are they like, oh you did such a good job.
Here's a little toy.
They look like someone's...
They look like someone's Gaia online avatar.
Oh my god, you do actually.
I don't think I have Giga on, on Steam.
I think I added her, but I don't think she accepted it yet.
I might have her.
Let me go left.
Let's see...
I added her, but she's offline.
Woah!
Yo, yo, change your mic.
What's up?
What was that?
Was that a bow?
What is that?
Can you get a fucking uh...
Oh no.
Is it better now?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, but you gotta up your volume more.
Turn it back.
I could feel it in my teeth.
It's very nostalgic.
Yeah, it's like going to one of those old static TVs and opening your mouth right next to it.
Someone's connecting to dial up right now.
Oh wait, I think that's... wait, is it Juniper?
Is Juniper dialed up?
Huh?
Okay, up my mic volume.
Whoa.
Wait, I'll mute.
I'll mute.
No, okay, you're good.
You're good.
You're okay, Juniper.
You're okay.
You're not static.
Everyone talk one at a time so we can like single out the person.
Snuffy said she wants an invite.
She needs an invite.
Oh, okay.
I'll get her in.
She has to be online.
How's my volume?
Oh my god.
We didn't discord nitro boost this.
We didn't.
Oh, there's Snuffy.
Is it yours?
Hi, hi.
Hello.
Hi.
Oh, Snuffy, you look great.
Okay.
Oh my god, you guys look fantastic.
Okay, who didn't do a tutorial?
Who didn't?
I didn't do the tutorial.
Okay.
I'll give you guys a quick rundown.
Okay, so it's 5v5.
So like there's only one L and one Kira.
So you either win by completing tasks as L or Kira or you kill L or you capture Kira.
And as Kira, Kira and Kira followers, you can talk to each other with a transmitter.
So like we can like secretly talk to each other.
So we're all investigators trying to find out who is Kira and who is Kira followers.
And if you're Kira, if you think you're getting sussed out, you can give your notebooks to other Kira followers so they become Kira.
And then when you're calling people out as the suspect during the meeting room phase, the L has to give the items to like another investigator, but that investigator could be a Kira follower.
So if you give the suspect items to a Kira follower accidentally, then the suspect is not arrested.
It's like, yeah, so it's like, yeah.
And then Kira followers and Kiras can steal your IDs by standing next to them.
And I can steal your ID and then we write down your name and you die.
So if I suddenly stand next to somebody and you're like, what the fuck are you standing next to me for?
They might be trying to steal your ID.
And then, yeah, so this one better do.
I am trying to explain the rules!
How did you guys get all these customized things?
Have you all wailed already?
You press T and then be like, please wait a moment.
Oh my god, keikaku dori.
I'm Kira.
When the Kira people go near you or anyone goes near you, it'll warn you saying your ID was stolen, but it doesn't mean they did steal it.
You're just supposed to put in your journal that that person was close enough to you to potentially steal it.
Yeah, so they don't actually steal it, but it's like, I think it would have been really funny if you hadn't clarified that and then people start screaming at each other.
So you gotta be like, I'll be the god of this new world.
Wait, how do you have the subtitles?
Oh, you go to T, and then you can be like, justice planned.
The first menu is like relatively useful stuff, and then it's like player callouts, and then it's like, I will be the god of this world.
Wait,
are we missing someone?
Yeah, we're missing Giga.
Giga's offline.
Have we heard from her?
Oh, okay, we have heard from Giga.
She said she was going to pee, so maybe she like fell in.
I don't think she's okay in the bathroom.
Is there like a Giga update?
Is she like, has she been gone on her stream for too long?
I'm becoming a player.
I like how you can just tell people to leave.
Like, actually, please leave.
Please leave me.
Please become a player.
Oh my god, that's worse than asking if you're AFK, just like...
So funny.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna adjust my volume just a little bit.
Let's see.
I'm going to refill my water while we wait for Giga.
Oh, she's still AFK.
Apparently, people are saying that she's still AFK on Steam.
I don't think she's okay in the bathroom right now.
I don't think she's okay.
There's a battle going on in there.
She made me run out of toilet paper.
No, no, somebody help her.
She has nobody.
She's crying at the door.
She's calling up for help.
We're just here.
She's in contact.
We're just here shitposting.
Oh my god, that's a real battle.
You can't beat the game.
God.
Just God.
Really one word.
God.
I need you guys to make sure that all of your audios is good, because I'm cooking something.
Okay, okay.
I don't know how it'll go, but I think it's great.
All right, are we all ready?
Giga's here.
Giga, can you say something so we can hear you?
Can you hear me?
Yeah, yeah, we can hear you.
Giga, were you okay in the bathroom?
Oh yeah, I sat in there for three years.
All right, you guys all ready?
I'm starting the game now.
Okay.
We can still talk in the loading screen.
Yeah, we can say what role we want.
I'm not gonna be Kira.
Right.
I'm not Kira.
Who could it be?
How could you be randomized?
That's interesting.
Oh my God, who's gonna be Kira?
I like how nobody wants to be the investigator.
Wait, why is there only two of us?
Oh, that's Kira.
Okay, that's Kira.
Okay.
Okay, VN.
No, no, no, we don't know who the other followers are.
Okay, Kira, give us the last items.
Oh, I shouldn't be proximity.
Sorry, I'll just push the time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hello?
Is this Kira?
Oh my God, Kira, I'm your biggest fan.
Okay, I need to turn down proximity, or I'm gonna get caught.
Wait, that don't wanna be Kira!
Okay,
okay, okay.
Now, now, now.
No, stop!
Stop!
They can see!
You keep pressing it too much!
Oh, wait, they can.
Wait, wait.
I need to go get some IDs or something, or I don't know.
Okay, I need to boost up.
Oh, you can boost people up yourself!
That's so cool!
Okay, let me get chat and chat mic.
Okay, there we go.
I guess I'm... Low key, I can't see anybody.
What the hell?
Okay, okay, you got...
I don't know!
Oh, wait, I know what to do.
Okay, you gotta... Okay, we gotta...
What's happening?
What happened?
Oh, what just happened?
Okay.
Okay, what happened today?
Oh my God, what just happened?
Okay, what happened?
Oh, investigator!
Good job!
Good job, guys!
Okay, so one criminal is dead.
Yeah, criminal.
We're even.
Oh my God, we're even, yeah.
It's one on one.
Where is everybody?
Speak up if you're... How do I know if my ID was taken?
My ID was taken.
Wait, is it supposed to be in my inventory?
I think Mint.
Mint?
Because as soon as I passed you, I got a notification that someone yoinked my ID.
No, that's just... That's just the automatic thing, I think.
It says...
So that, she could have easily stood next to her and yoinked it.
Okay, because Lime said that, I'm gonna vote for her too.
I have to follow her.
I think I'm gonna vote for her.
I knew I would say that, and so they made an arbitrary rule.
I have a question.
How the fuck am I supposed to investigate other players?
Because I failed my investigation.
Can you, like, retract your, like...
What happens if you shamelessly point fingers, like...
Well, they get arrested, so like, they basically...
Oh, they get tied to you, so we should...
If we want to, like, suss somebody out, they get, like, handcuffed to the person that got sussed out.
I don't want that.
You don't want to be handcuffed?
I have a question.
Wait, I have a question.
Yeah?
Who is Kira?
Just...
I don't know, Kira.
Who is it?
I wanna say, I think Mint and Amelie are both suspicious.
I'm suspicious?
I'm just an investigator.
Nobody won't be suspicious yet.
Nobody has any fucking clue what we're doing.
Doki, why did you vote for me?
Because I saw Bao voted for you, and Bao seems to know what she's doing.
I'm not Kira.
That's what Kira would say.
But you can skip both?
I'm not looking for that outfit, not gonna lie.
Look at that.
Look at that wig.
Yeah, I mean, look at it.
You're hating on me because I'm styling?
That's so messed up.
Mint is, like, impersonating Elle.
She's doing trick shots on us.
Yeah.
Alright, Kira, who are you gonna vote for?
Wait, lots of people are voting for me.
This is kind of crazy.
Kira, who are you voting for?
No, you just get handcuffed.
Nobody.
And every day we don't vote is another death on our hands.
Shut me in jail.
I can't take it anymore.
No one was arrested.
Why are we in class?
Vienna, Vienna, Vienna, Vienna.
Get over here, Vienna, Vienna, Vienna.
Good luck.
Alright, thank God.
I don't want to be Kira anymore.
There's too much pressure.
Hello?
Where are you going, Grimmy?
Where are you going?
Well, where are you going, huh?
Yeah, what are you investigating, huh?
Alright, alright.
You can't even tell me what you're investigating.
Where's, where's, uh, I need to find...
What
is happening?
How'd you die?
You died!
Oh!
That was fast.
Pawn falls.
How did that happen?
Yay!
Oh my gosh!
We were supposed to protect Elle!
How did you know?
It's over, dude.
It's over.
Vienna, how did you do it?
How did they know?
They're too good, they're too good.
Vienna, how did you know, Vienna?
Vienna is not, is muted.
She's so good, she won't even say it.
A silent killer.
She won't even tell us.
She's like, I won't, I don't reveal secrets.
Vienna did the tutorial.
I just hear, I hear like some...
Oh.
Wait!
Oh my god, we get to get cosmetics!
Audio source.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I got Elle's laptop.
She's trying to communicate.
There's a mosquito in the lobby.
I have his laptop right here.
If you want to talk to Elle, come here.
I am Elle, stop impersonating me.
It's like so confusing that there's like...
Laimu is just Elle, so I'm like, wait, is Laimu Elle?
Press B, Vienna!
Press B!
I was like, oh no, not me.
Oh, no, it's not me.
Hold it?
Yeah, hold it and talk.
Oh, that works.
Vienna, what happened?
She was talking earlier to me.
She was talking earlier.
Oh, no!
It's Morse code.
I just want to know how she did it.
How did she do it?
I want to know her secrets.
She's so good.
I was actually playing the tutorials and stuff before we started, and it's like one of the only people that did that.
Oh my god.
I played the tutorials.
Oh, no!
Oh, she's going so hard.
I sabotaged her so she couldn't explain anything.
Kira's got her.
That's a real death note.
Oh my god.
If you go to customize, and go to cut-ins, and you see last words, I got one that was like, I'll post your name on the internet.
I'm gonna die.
Why?
If you die...
I think if you get arrested, that's what you say.
Oh my god.
I love that.
The last words.
I'm gonna post your name on the internet.
Oh my god.
I would...
Wanna go for a drink after this?
Why am I rising up the...
There's one in last words that's like, kill me.
Just kill me.
There's one for Elle that says, am I a freak?
Warning.
I am not.
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh, these nameplates are so...
Are your guys' like, sounds in English or Japanese?
Does it...
Mine is in Japanese.
I think there's only Japanese.
Only, I think.
Oh yeah, we found out that this game is not available in Japan.
Yeah.
Is it in Japanese?
I asked Henya if she wanted to join, and she was like, the game's not available for me.
Not available in Japan.
You know how many games I've tried to play with her, and she's like, I can't play it because I'm in Japan.
That's so sad.
Why is it Reason exclusive when it's literally Death Note?
In Japanese, too.
The dumbest in Japanese audio.
I guess they don't want to play Among Us.
Yeah, yeah.
Only it's Nostalgia Bay for us.
Oh yeah.
Okay, Vienna's restarting the game.
I like how she tried to tell us a couple of times, and it was just...
I was like, I think I'm starting to understand.
Yeah, can't Kira like, coordinate between all of you guys and like, talk to you in secret?
Yeah, that's what we were doing.
It worked earlier.
We were like, talking to each other.
We were handing the notebooks to each other.
We were just like...
I am Kira from the great beyond.
Can we actually talk over like, a loudspeaker?
Like, everyone hears you?
No, only the good team or the bad team hears you.
So Kira can only talk to the killer people.
Kira can only talk to the aligned people.
And Elle can talk to the investigators.
I was Elle, and I knew how to look through the camera.
So I was able to like, see those.
But I don't know how to talk to everyone.
I'm looking out for Kira followers.
Actually, no.
I think two was enough.
I mean, we literally got Elle the first time.
Can you hear me now?
Yeah, we can hear you!
Tell us your secrets!
How did you know?
I stole Giga's ID, and then wrote her name in the book, and she was Elle.
So we won.
Masterful Giga.
The one person you stole.
People are just going to spend the entire time sprinting away from you.
Alright, alright.
I find it funny that anybody who...
gets so much close to me, I'm just like, you're fucking dead.
You have to be Kira.
I was like, it's chill if I write her name down, right?
So it was just a lucky guess?
Yeah, it was just a lucky guess.
So like, there's tasks where investigators have to be next to a person, so an investigator could be next to a person just investigating them.
So it throws you off.
Are you guys ready?
Let's do it again.
Alright, here we go.
Alright,
I picked... I'm not Kira this time.
I wanna be a hot girl.
You wanna be Misa?
Yeah.
I wanna be a goth girl.
Being Kira is stressful.
I think 2v8 is fine.
Yeah, she kept like, passing it.
Passing it.
Alright, I'm an investigator.
Wait, who's L?
Who's L then?
Oh no.
Hot investigator.
Oh, hey.
Hi.
Yeah, I'm a hot investigator too.
I doubt that.
Oh yeah, I'm gonna write your name.
I'm gonna put your name on the internet.
I'm coming over, I'm coming over.
Coming over.
Wait, what's happening?
Death note test.
Oh, we got fixed it.
Oh, resolve the incident to prevent the new world.
I'm resolving.
Somebody else help me resolve.
Oh, I'm still resolving.
A body was found.
A body was found at the meeting room.
We know L!
We know!
Sure.
I'm still...
Please!
It's just me!
I'm still trying to resolve!
By 10?
There's no way.
Do I make it?
There's no way!
Oh, 3, 2...
Oh, I got it!
I just got it in time.
Oh, thank god.
I literally just got it in time.
I did it.
I'm a hero.
Oh, Snuffy, what are you doing over here?
I was following the little alert thing.
Yeah?
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Yeah, I just did it.
I had to do it by myself.
Oh, hello.
Investigate.
No one's been by today before you got here.
Okay, no one's been here.
So we're fine.
Oh...
A little...
Hmm...
Let's see...
Okay, we got the testimonies here.
Wait, they already have one!
Whoa, whoa!
Why is there so many people?
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
Why are you getting close to me?
Why are you getting close?
Six feet, six feet!
People keep giving me lost items.
I don't know what it means.
Okay, I need a monitor.
Alright, where's LimeMoon?
I need a monitor here.
Like a good investigator.
Oh...
Oh!
It's Snuffy!
I saw her open the notebook!
We got a trial meeting!
It's Snuffy!
Snuffy, what were you doing?
I was reading my notebook.
Is it possibly a black notebook?
It was my investigation notebook.
Why would you walk so close to me?
Oh...
SodaScar...
I have a problem.
Hmm...
I...
Didn't know how to.
That's a very lucky...
That's a very likely story.
Yeah, but there's...
There's a Kira follower too.
My ID was stolen!
Oh my god!
Okay, so, I...
I think it's Snuffy.
Because I saw her bring up the notebook...
In the corner as if she was hiding something.
And I think that notebook...
I think that notebook was black.
No-no.
I saw it was a black notebook.
Aymo, did you steal my notebook?
Yeah, you would say that, wouldn't you, Kira?
Yeah,
I was resolving the last body by myself because Mint walked away.
She walked away.
There's still a follower out there!
We gotta get all of them, and I remember before she was like, I wanna be just like Misa.
My ID was stolen.
My social security is on the line right now.
I think there's more to worry about than your social security if it got stolen.
Vote for Limu because you had a little magnifying glass after you walked by me.
You were looking at my ID.
I lost nothing!
You lost your ID!
What do you mean?
Oh, I lost my ID.
That's right.
Is it in your bag now?
Cause I gave you an item and I got experience for doing it.
Oh, I have... Oh, wait.
No, I have no items.
Oh...
I also had a prompt to deliver Minto a lost item.
Wait, maybe she just keeps losing her ID.
Everybody has my ID, apparently.
Whoa!
It's like... It's like you want to get killed.
Yeah, I voted for Snuffy.
Yeah, Snuffy.
Defend yourself.
Yeah?
You know, I didn't... Oh, wait.
Who was gonna confiscate the item?
Me.
What items?
I'm good.
No, don't give it to Doki.
What do you mean?
I'm the one that called her out.
What the... Who's that?
Who is this?
Oh, is it Snuffy?
One...
Oh my god.
Why are they zooming in on the face?
Oh, they're publishing the name.
I knew it!
I knew!
Oh my god!
Those live reactions.
That's right.
Snuffy was killed.
Oh, yeah.
Woo!
We won!
We did it!
Okay, I'm gonna increase the...
I got a match.
I got a...
And I don't know what to do!
Okay, I'll...
I'll add more Akira followers.
Really?
Okay, you can do that?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can increase it.
Okay, glasses.
Oh my god, his last word.
Okay.
My apologies, Snuffy.
I wasn't good enough.
That's okay!
It was the first time trying to figure it out.
Yeah, I like how...
I didn't know it would just be so obvious.
I tried to hide in the corner.
And, like, away from the camera.
It just, like, it's so obvious if you're looking at it.
Yeah, I was just like, what are you doing in the corner?
You have to do, like, the same, like, button thing.
I think I would just have to click on something, but you have to do, like, a button.
Okay, let's see.
Like, if you want to go kill somebody, make sure you're, like, ready to do, like, a...
Like, a quick button press.
Like, the W-W-B thing.
Okay, okay.
Q-T-E that shit.
I feel like the map isn't big enough.
Like, we're always bumping into each other.
I think there is different... I don't know if there's a different map now.
I'm checking the settings right now.
The first part with the body thing, what even was that?
Oh, you...
I don't know.
It was, like, a bunch of crimes, but the amount of time we had to resolve the crimes was fucking minuscule.
So, it was, like, impossible to...
Can they do that?
Oh, I can make it so every player has black notebooks.
Oh, that's good.
Yeah, I'm gonna add that.
All players have black notebooks.
So, like, people will be like...
Oh, we totally know how to play this game.
So, that was really easy to learn.
Serious, let's see.
We're still figuring it out.
I'm sure if we get a round or two, we'll get the hang of it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, let's see.
We're 1-1 right now for bad and good guys.
I'm gonna turn down the meeting hours.
So, less discussion.
Yeah.
Okay.
Does the notebooks look different than the death note?
Well, yeah, they do.
Not anymore.
I made it so they're all black.
Yeah, they're all gonna be...
Yeah, yeah.
So, we take our notebooks out.
It's gonna be, like, black.
So, we don't know if it's an actual death note or not.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna check if there's other settings.
Is there a way to increase the time for the sabotage?
Whatever happened?
The sabotage?
Oh, like, when...
A round increase would be good.
A round increase time would be nice.
Okay, increasing the round.
Uh...
Day, night?
I think that's it.
I'll do 90 seconds.
Okay, let's try it.
90 seconds, and then...
I'm checking if there's anything else.
Uh...
I think we could do that for now, and then we'll adjust the settings later.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, starting now.
Woohoo!
Let's go!
Oh, I could...
Oh, I think...
Oh, I can turn off role selection next game.
Oh, wait.
I don't think it matters though, because every time I've pressed Kira follower, nothing happens.
No!
Oh, wait!
Is this what you want, but it won't always give it to you, I guess?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, I never press confirm!
Oh my God.
Okay.
A rescue...
Alright.
This time, it's so easy.
Oh.
Hello, Snuffy.
Hello.
Why are you running away?
Whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Why did you just walk closer to me, huh?
No, no, no.
I was...
I just wanted to say hi.
Okay, I gotta question some NPCs.
Oh, are you guys questioning NPCs?
Oh.
Oh, hello.
Oh, are you interrogating them?
Okay, I'm gonna interrogate them too.
No one stopped by.
Okay.
Where's the other...
Where's the other guy?
Yeah, she's a little sussy there.
She was.
W-S.
Nice.
No one's been here.
Uh, hint?
Okay, I have...
There's nothing not good intel.
Whoa!
What are you trying to do, Amelie?
Huh?
What are you trying to...
What's your task?
I'm a little investigator.
This is my weapon of choice.
Every...
How did you get that?
I leveled up.
I've got an anime by my side.
I pay to win.
I completed my task, but no one's dead yet.
Oh?
Can contact...
To publicly reveal their role?
Stuffy, reveal yourself!
Oh, Limus!
Limus...
Limus investigator, she's safe.
She's safe.
Oh no.
Nothing?
I have surveyed.
Okay, let's see.
I still have my ID card.
My task list.
Okay, I need to question some NPCs.
Hey guys.
Limus is safe, so we don't have to worry about her.
Oh, hey.
I'm just interrogating.
Nothing suspicious.
Who did she see?
Before you two people came by.
No, no, no.
It might be still him, but that means it's still with me.
It has Sans Undertale on it.
What?
Where's the last investigation?
Where's the last witness?
Here?
Oh, there you are.
Who else talked to you?
Three people?
Oh my god, you whore.
Okay.
Whoa, all of you guys.
Hey guys.
What did you guys do for your task?
Huh?
I wanted to just see something.
Put your names on the internet.
Oh no!
No!
What the hell?
What happened?
Oh my god.
No!
Lime!
Not Lime, bro.
Oh my god.
What did we do?
Okay, who specified that she had such a horrible death?
Yeah, literally could've picked heart attack.
She's gonna post her names on the internet.
Oh my god.
I was accusing Lime for standing too close to me and then the next second a car hit her.
We literally saw that she's an investigator.
Yeah, we saw that.
Yeah.
Maybe you were in the notebook.
I can't believe she got e-cigar.
Speak up.
A dying message.
My ID was stolen.
My ID was stolen too!
That'll do it, bro.
Wait a minute.
My thing says, Emily seems to have been in close contact with many people so they might be L.
Wait, wait, who stood next to me?
Somebody stood next to me and I was like, that'd be funny if they took my ID.
And they did!
Who was it?
Uh-oh.
That's your fault.
You need to pay attention.
Wait, I think...
Because I don't have an ID either.
Wait, I think it was Vienna.
I saw someone write in a notebook right before that happened on the left side of the map.
I was watching Doopie.
My notebook out.
Doopie always has...
It's like a heart attack because everybody pulls out the death.
That's really scary.
That's very specific.
I think Juniper would do something that specific.
I wouldn't do something... I never do specific things.
Oh, who do we vote for?
Okay, buddy.
I don't know.
I'm skipping.
My God, somebody actually died and now we're not, like, accusing somebody right now.
Look at me, I have this camera.
I literally accused somebody.
No one was arrested.
Snuffy, was it you?
Did you take my ID?
Was it you?
Was it you, Snuffy?
You already took my ID.
I can stand next to you now.
You wanna kill me, right, Snuffy?
You wanna do it?
Why are you running away?
I don't have an ID.
Snuffy, I'm calling for you.
Okay, we have surveillance cameras.
Oh God, we gotta help Elle.
We gotta help our guy.
Okay, I'm gonna head over here first.
I'm gonna talk to him.
Okay, nice.
Supposedly...
Wait, supposedly someone handed... What?
Supposedly, I saw someone handing off an ID during the day at the street near the park convenience store?
Wait a minute.
Somebody was... Oh, that's where Lime died.
Right here.
Yeah.
Oh?
What's that?
Death note test.
Oh, oh, oh!
We gotta do it!
We gotta go, we gotta go, we gotta go!
We have to... Just go, just go, just go!
There's a dead body.
Okay, if there's two of us resolving, it'll be faster.
It's okay, I don't have an ID, so I trust you.
Wait, your ID was stolen too?
Yeah, everything's stolen.
I had Lime's notebook and it wouldn't let me open it.
So I can't even tell you what was inside.
Wait, no, you have to give it to L!
Wait, wait, Snuffy, Snuffy, why weren't you saying anything when you did all that?
Snuffy, you're so quiet.
Snuffy?
Snuffy, what's going on?
Yeah, what's going on?
What are the vibes right now?
Snuffy, are you muted?
You're not pressing V.
Oh, Snuffy is a little too quiet.
Snuffy?
Oh God, she's trying to get rid of us.
Oh, Snuffy?
I'm taking notes right now.
I'm taking your notes.
I'm gonna take notes over your notes.
I think she wrote our names, Val!
I think it's... I think it's Snuffy.
I think it's Snuffy.
You're so sus right now, Snuffy.
You're not saying anything.
Yeah, give item back.
Who do I give this item to?
Thank you.
Oh.
God, lost item.
Whose items is this?
Grimmy, Grimmy, here's an item!
I'm here to get... You lose something!
Okay, nice.
I already have my ID stolen, so you don't have to worry.
Okay.
We go this way.
How can you steal my ID twice?
Supposedly, someone's talking during the day at a street near the classroom cafe.
Where's the...
Why are you guys just... Are you guys on transmitter talking to each other right now, right here?
Are you guys... Are you guys on... Are you guys out here on the corner?
Yeah.
My ID is already stolen.
I have no fear.
I know I'm gonna die anyway.
What?
How?
Who is that?
Oh yeah, someone's a mosquito again.
Oh my...
I fucking knew it!
I knew it, Snuffy!
I said Snuffy!
I called her out!
Snuffy couldn't hear you guys for what it was worth.
Like, she said she couldn't hear you.
Oh, really?
I was really scared that that was like a feature if I was Kida.
Cause like, I could only hear when Vienna talked to me over the communications, but everybody else was dead silent.
I couldn't hear anybody.
Oh, that's weird.
I don't think that's supposed to happen.
Yeah, I don't think that was...
Cause I could talk to people.
I kept trying to go around being like, I can't hear anybody.
I'm sorry, but I just...
Yeah, I was like trying to call you out and you wouldn't respond.
Alright,
let's see.
Should we turn down the day-night cycle?
I can hear you fine.
Is that okay?
Did we turn down the day-night?
Yeah, I think it was alright.
Let's see what other stuff I can adjust.
I know we can like do a...
You don't have to choose what you want to be.
Where is it though?
What's the setting chat in?
Like investigator and it was just like you.
No, I picked follower and it made me Kira and I was like, what?
I didn't even pick this.
Okay.
No problem, I've done it before.
Where's the randomizer?
Wait, who?
Who's?
Oh, yeah.
Should I...
Oh, wait.
Kira got her.
Kira.
I have to apologize to her.
She has to come back.
Where the fuck is...
Did you hear my epic music though?
Yeah, it was good.
It was good.
Alright, I've got the randomizer on so it'll randomly give you roles.
Okay.
Let's see.
Nobody point fingers at me because, you know, the laws of probability would say that I wouldn't be Kira again.
We'll vote Snuffy out first.
Now he'll be a liable partner, you know, so you'll be like, dang, Snuffy could be Elle, which means she's gigabrain and super cool and...
I realized I accidentally outed myself because I said something only the Shinigami can tell you about Amelie and nobody noticed.
Literally, it's our third game.
I don't think we could...
Yeah, I'm pretty sure nobody fucking knows.
It's okay.
We're all learning live as we go along.
So be careful if you're the bad guy.
If that was okay, I hope Kira didn't...
I can't... Okay, wait, Snuffy, so you killed Lime like that?
Yeah, that's so fu... Lime, how does that feel?
I swiped my ID because I had to investigate her, which meant that I was like cuddling up real close.
Yeah, I think it's definitely...
I just miss Lime's...
I definitely think it's really hard with... It's like... I don't know how to describe it.
It's really hard with the notebooks or without them because then everybody's pulling out the death note and I could probably just kill somebody in front of everybody and nobody could ever like question that.
Oh, true.
So you want me to turn...
I feel like Kira's...
I think you should probably run away or have to hide to do the death noting thing.
Alright, I'm gonna... Okay, I turned the notebooks back to...
Like Kira... Only Kira is black notebook then, yeah.
So right now it's kind of like... Kira can just get lucky.
Yeah, yeah.
He just looks at everybody putting out the notebook and he's like, I'm gonna write people's names right now in front of everybody.
I'm just running around being like, I can't hear anything and...
Oh, apparently...
That might not be...
Apparently, Bao might not be back, guys.
So I guess we'll...
We'll start it off then.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, I'm an investigator.
You're a random fuck.
I just want to give other people a chance to play.
I don't want to be Kira or Elle.
Yeah, Bao, there's something...
Uh...
Your internet died, so...
Hello, I'm proximity voice.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
What if I take your ID card right now?
I'm gonna impersonate you right here.
Identity theft is not a joke.
Alright, let's see...
Question, NPC... Oh, that's one of them.
They say like stuff like...
Oh, uh...
Somebody did this at this time.
And like, how am I supposed to know?
How am I supposed to know that?
Like, who did that?
Like, I don't have the brains to figure that out.
Hey, where's Grimmy?
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Grimmy, I'm gonna need to stand next to you.
I need to monitor you.
It's monitoring.
Alright.
Grimmy and Snuff... You two were close to me.
What do you want?
Not long enough, though.
I mean, if you really think about it...
Yeah, I'm gonna investigate you, too.
I'm gonna...
Lime, wouldn't it be funny if you were Kira?
You're the only person I stood next to, so my ID is gone.
Yeah.
Yeah, wouldn't that be funny?
Why are you guys kissing?
I have my eye on you and Grimmy.
I'm just saying...
She's trying to mind game me.
I'm saying that like...
This is the only person I stood next to, so like, if something happens, if my ID is gone, I'm just saying...
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, get away.
Get away.
Don't be sussy right now.
I'm writing it down.
I wrote your name down.
I received a lost item.
Oh, thank you.
Okay, who talked to you, sir?
Two people came to him.
Okay.
I like how useless the fucking testimony is.
Yeah, I know.
They're like, four people.
Yes, it's like, what am I supposed to do with that information?
They like, walked up to him.
What am I supposed to do?
I think it's like, L.
I think you have to tell L.
Like, they'll be like, oh, I saw somebody at this location, and you have to tell L to like, check the camera.
Yeah, but who's L?
Are you L?
You have... No, you have to...
Oh, okay, I need to go here.
Who am I monitoring?
Okay, who am I monitoring?
Amelie.
Okay, where's Amelie?
Oh, make room for me.
Why are you in the corner down there?
Huh?
Why are you in the corner down there, huh?
Are you trying to write in the notebook in the corner?
Is that what you're trying to do?
That feels weird.
Damn, it feels a little sussy for you to be in that corner by yourself.
Oh!
Oh, death note test?
What's that?
Resolve incidents?
Oh...
Okay, okay, okay, I'm resolving right here.
Oh, Doopie, I don't like how you're so close to me.
Where's the...
It's over here.
Hello, Vienna.
Let's resolve stuff together.
Wait a minute.
There was another person next to me and they're not next to me anymore.
There were people next to... Oh!
They get the last one.
We didn't do the last one.
Oh, did it!
It's solved!
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god, that was close.
That was close.
Any up... Amelie and Grimmie's voice.
Okay, give me a sec.
I'm standing in this corner.
I think I still have my ID.
There's no way.
What are you doing next to me?
What are you...
I'm trying to up my volume.
What are you doing?
Me?
Yeah, what are you doing?
I wasn't next to you.
I was in a storage closet.
Oh, did Kira do anything?
We killed one criminal.
Isn't that good?
Yeah, it's good for Kira.
No, we're trying to stop them from killing criminals.
That's the whole point.
Oh my gosh, my ID was stolen.
Oh my god.
There goes my ID.
My ID.
Who was it?
Identity fraud is not a joke.
It didn't get stolen, so I actually think Mintz might be Chill.
I am Chill.
I had contact with a lot of people today.
I had contact with...
I think, like, Grimmy, Doki, Snuffy, Amelie, and Mintz.
So, god fucking knows who it was.
I had contact with the only person who didn't seem like they were near anybody.
No, you weren't.
Doki's the only person I was next to.
I was literally with...
Doki weren't.
I ran away from you.
No, I was right next to...
You're the only person I actually went next to.
No fucking...
Look, okay, I was next to Lime and Vienna.
Alright, my ID is safe.
Okay, no one was...
That sounds like a scam.
Okay.
Alright, round two.
You tell me you're a hero follower, right?
Nope.
Oh, who, who?
Me?
Check that out, see that?
No one's been here before me.
Oh, surveillance.
Don't worry, don't worry.
L, I got you!
Maybe not, I don't know where it is.
Oh, how do I get into this room?
Okay, got it.
We're doing it.
We're gonna save the world.
I need to monitor you.
If my ID is taken...
Juniper, if my ID is taken, I know why.
Wait.
Alright.
What does he have to say?
Before you...
Okay, that's so...
Are they gonna give us helpful things?
Testimonies?
Woah!
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Okay.
You're not Kira, are you?
What the fuck?
No, I'm not.
Hence.
Okay, trying to see if anybody has their notebook out.
See, I was also next to Juniper, so...
So, if my ID is gone, I know.
What?
Your ID was stolen anyway, so it doesn't matter if I'm here.
It doesn't matter.
I'm gonna...
Oh!
Oh my God!
I gotta investigate this guy.
Wow, two people?
Really?
Who is that two people?
Okay, Amelie.
Where is she?
Amelie!
Amelie, I need to touch you for a sec.
Amelie, get back here!
Wait, what?
How am I missing?
Okay, there you go.
Once the world accepts the way, Kira thinks someone...
These are not even investigations!
Oh my God, where the fuck is...
Where is Amelie?
Amelie!
I need to touch Amelie!
Amelie, I need to touch you!
Okay.
Alright, nice.
I investigated you.
If I lose my ID, I swear to God.
My ID is gone after I touched you.
I swear to God.
Okay.
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Yeah, yeah, okay.
You're gonna steal my ID right now?
Are you gonna identity theft me?
Are you gonna touch me and then take my identity?
It's not a joke, you know that, right?
I think there's something wrong with Kira.
He's not been doing anything.
What's he nervous about?
Just write something.
Do it, Amelie!
Write in your book right now!
In front of me.
I won't say anything.
Wait, what?
Yenna won't say anything too.
You're already a fine shinigami?
Wait, what?
What happened?
Oh my God.
She just walked away.
She went to heaven!
Oh my God.
Okay.
That's not heaven.
That's what I call heaven.
That was absolutely not heaven.
That's my bad.
That's the bonus cutscene.
That reveal left us hanging.
Oh my God.
I like how they didn't even kill the criminals.
They killed us instead.
Okay.
Do you get a new ID every round?
Or once your video ID is gone, you're just in danger of getting murdered?
I think it's just gone, gone.
Yeah, I think.
That's a good question.
If you only have one?
Anyway...
Did anybody get theirs re-stolen?
Oh my God.
No, I didn't want to press the button!
I think you can get your IDs back if we vote somebody out that might have your ID.
We can get it back.
Yeah, yeah.
We should need to call somebody out.
Wait, I have a dying message.
Where do I find it?
Oh, maybe in your investigation notepad?
Oh.
You need to call somebody out, Doki.
That sounds like a thing Kira would want us to do.
I found Groomy's investigation notepad, but it doesn't tell me anything.
Oh, I guess she wasn't doing her job.
It takes longer to do the voting if we do actually find stuff like that, because it's about to end and we haven't even...
Okay, yeah, we gotta get...
It didn't even give me a dying message.
Okay, I'm voting, I'm voting!
It was random, it was not targeted, I swear.
It was not targeted, I just clicked the closest thing.
Hopefully, we're gaming.
Okay.
I'm a little worried here.
I'm a little worried.
Okay, who do I... Okay, question Vienna.
An NPC.
Vienna!
Vienna, get back here!
Don't run away from me, I swear to God!
It's not weird!
Oh.
Okay, her notebook.
Who does she see?
LDKoi?
Oh, no one opens a notebook?
What does that mean?
Vienna, I need to investigate.
I need to investigate you.
I need to investigate...
I need to investigate you first.
Okay.
I have... I have Mint's notebook, but...
How do I find out?
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
She was sus of me.
She was only sus of me?!
I found her body, and the only thing she had in her fucking notebook was that she sus of me.
That's it.
Okay, Mint, we're never gonna...
We're never gonna fucking get him.
God really is on my side.
Wait, what's this?
Oh!
Oh, that was close.
I almost got isekai'd.
Okay.
Oh, hey guys, a lot of...
I'm gonna make sure that...
I'm making sure...
Oh, Juniper, what are you trying to do?
Are you trying to steal IDs, Juniper?
Are you trying to...
I'm trying to make sure, you know, people don't...
You know, I'm making sure I'm guiding...
Wait!
Wait, how did he just...
How did he just die?!
Guys!
Lime just died in front of...
I didn't even see!
Guys!
I just died in front of...
Dominate and Lime just died in front of...
Guys!
Snuffy, where were you, Snuffy?
Snuffy, where were you?
I just disappeared.
Two people died.
Where were you?
Nobody was right...
Two people died.
Where were you?
Where were you at, huh?
Stop approaching me!
Oh, shit!
Snuffy, why did you take the...
Notebook!
I accidentally threw the notebook out!
Snuffy, read the notebook, Snuffy.
Read the notebook.
I think you're...
It's an attack!
Oh, okay.
I think...
Oh, no.
I think it's Snuffy.
There's no way.
There's so little people left.
Guys, where's L?
Where's L?
I think it's Snuffy and Juniper.
Yeah, I think it's Snuffy or...
Wait.
I think it's...
I think it's Snuffy or Juniper.
Okay, let me write this down in my trusty notebook.
I can't believe it.
They just died in front of me and nobody cared.
They just...
L assigned a joint investigation?
Okay, I think it has to be...
Okay.
It has to be these two.
How do we...
How do we set up a meeting?
L!
Whoever you are, set up a meeting, L!
I know who it is!
It's...
It's not me!
What are you guys doing?
What are you guys just...
Are you guys talking to each other?
We're just, you know...
Hanging out.
Oh, I can finally hear voices.
I'll post your names on the internet.
Oh no!
That's how Lime died!
Wait!
Oh no!
No.
They're gonna dox.
I have no idea what's going on.
Yeah, that's what Akira would say.
That's what Akira would say right there.
It looks suspicious, but it's not!
The game's fucked up!
I think...
I think it's Snuffy.
I think it's Snuffy also.
Lime!
I'm sorry, Snuffy.
Lime and...
I have no idea what's even going on, so I can't even say, like...
Guys, I'm doing my investigation!
Oh my god, all the criminals are dead!
We've been helping with the tasks, but I'm sorry I can't, like...
Oh!
Okay, that's not good.
It's not good.
We got...
Come on, investigators!
We're just almost there!
Snuffy was alone.
Oh, my ID was stolen?
I know who was next to me.
I know, like...
Vienna and Jupi were next to me a lot.
No, but then I...
I stood next to a lot of people after that.
And then I stood next to...
Vienna, and I stood next to a lot...
I'm gonna vote Snuffy.
How am I making calculated moves?
Wait, maybe it's...
Maybe it's Juniper, because, like...
She's...
Did Doki help with the investigations?
The two that we did?
Yeah, I did.
I did, and then I saw Lime...
Because I don't know.
I saw, and then I was...
I was gonna do one, and I saw Lime, and...
Amelie just fucking...
Collapsed.
Guys, we need...
Oh, my God.
Guys, I'm...
It's over.
It's...
We need...
We literally...
No!
Doki!
You deserve that.
No...
You honestly deserve that.
Oh, my God.
No!
My heart is...
Can you call...
Can you call meetings in this, I wonder?
I think L can.
Oh, my God.
Oh, L can...
Who killed you?
Who killed you guys?
What are you talking about?
It's Snuffy.
I knew...
I told...
I fucking...
I knew it.
I was like, it has to be Snuffy.
It has to be Snuffy.
The camera's right there.
Oh, my God.
Wait, who is...
Juniper is L, and there's a...
Snuffy is like killing people right in front of the camera.
Nobody believed me.
I fucking knew it.
I'm gonna fucking pee in anger.
I'll be right back.
Oh, wait.
They just revealed Vienna's role, so now everybody will know that it's Snuffy.
I don't think they know that those people are dead, though.
Yeah.
They don't see it until the end of the round.
Oh, true.
I think...
Oh, no.
This is so bad.
They're not gonna make it.
Oh, okay.
I think Bao is back.
Yippee!
Oh, my gosh.
Stay away.
All she needs is your ID.
I actually wonder if, balance-wise, it's better to have shorter rounds...
Because it feels like it's way too easy to steal everybody's fucking IDs at this point.
Yeah, yeah.
It's stressing me out.
I wish I could move around as a ghost.
I know.
You can watch the people, but you can't move.
You have to, like, pick one to spectate.
You open your little investigator list and click on somebody.
It's literally, like...
Wait, it's like...
They have to just figure out...
Is it just one...
One Kira, and then it's Vienna and Juniper against Snuffy?
Yeah, there's no Kira helper, for some reason.
Oh, I guess it's, like, random.
Are you serious?
Are you fucking...
Oh my god!
Can you get hit by the car?
What just happened?
Can you imagine after all that, Kira gets hit by a fucking car?
I fucking knew it was you.
Oh my god.
There she is!
Oh no, she's making her move!
Oh my god.
She's investigating.
What?
Juniper just gave Snuffy...
She's stealing IDs.
So bad.
It's not me.
Wait, so the further the days go, do, like, more events happen?
That's kind of fun.
Yeah, they start saying different things, like the witnesses.
Yeah.
Please, please just...
L, call a meeting, L!
Just call a meeting!
I don't call a meeting!
You know that there's only three of you left!
Who's L?
Juniper.
We're just letting Snuffy do whatever she wants!
She caught me!
She knew I was out there and she took my life!
Do you have trouble getting back in?
Like, the invites aren't working?
Yeah, I can invite her.
I think we have to be in the lobby again.
Yeah.
Oh, maybe.
Yeah, okay.
I fucking knew it.
I knew she wasn't... I knew she wasn't real.
How does she keep getting L, though?
Alright, Kira, I mean...
I think... I don't know.
I think there's just something about it.
Stupid L costume.
There's something about it.
I like it, though.
I'll post your names on the Internet!
It's on the Internet!
Oh my God, it's you!
Damn, look at him.
That's me.
With your sword!
No!
Juniper, I swear to God.
That was Doki!
Oh my God!
We still have a dad!
One of us is L, one of us is Kira, and one of us is, like, John Adam.
It's Snoopy!
I swear it's Snoopy!
You guys saw that Vienna is... Vienna is an investigator and it's Snoopy!
It's like...
I signed you two to work together because all three of us were in a room together!
And I was like, this is how I can prove to them that I'm safe!
It's Snoopy!
We did it!
If you just couldn't pick them, then if you tried to assign an investigation to somebody like that, it would just be like, sorry, that guy's evil, you can't pick them.
He's yapping.
Oh my God.
Snoopy, you are talking so good right now, but I...
It is you.
I can't say anything because I can't hear anybody.
You are talking so fucking good!
He's using the I can't hear anybody excuse.
I can't hear anyone.
Oh my God, here it is.
Here it is.
Sweet justice, sweet justice.
I wish we could hear you during the round.
You can't hear me either?
I can't hear anybody and you can't hear me?
You were, like, running at me.
I was trying to tell Junie I had to investigate her.
How did she win that?
Oh my God.
I'm a genius, that's how.
Why did you kill us?
I'm so confused.
I can't, there's a maximum number of people you can kill every day, so I just tried to write everybody's names down.
You can't kill any people until the next day.
So it was basically, like, me blindly picking because I had nobody to give me, like, IDs or tell me anything.
That's so sad.
Let's be random then.
Okay.
That's weird that you couldn't hear anybody.
Yeah, yeah, I just sent an invite to her.
I just sent it.
That's so weird that you couldn't hear anybody because we could hear you.
Oh!
Okay, I'll restart.
Restart, restart.
How do I restart the lobby?
How do I get out of here?
Oh, there it is.
Yeah.
Alright, create room.
Let's see.
Role selection off.
Voice chat on.
Create room.
Okay, now I need to add people in.
I hope that Guess Game gets more updates and, like, more stuff is added to it.
Because, like, I can only put on one person as an ally, but it said you can do five.
So I was like, how do you get five people as an ally?
Hello!
I'm trying to figure out how to get five people in, like, as a cure ally.
Because it only said one for me.
It's like one or zero and I'm like, what?
Okay, Juniper.
I don't know if I got everybody.
Who was that?
Oh, my bad.
My bad.
What?
Did it happen again?
Yeah, you're on the webcam again.
No, ten players is the max, guys.
That's the thing.
Ten players is max.
You're better.
That's good.
Two, four, six.
Yeah, we can hear you.
Okay, I'm genuinely wondering...
If you get cured and you can't hear people, it seems almost like it's intentional.
Because I can start hearing people almost immediately as voting starts, but I don't know why.
Oh, maybe.
No, no, no, no, because I was cured.
That would be stupid, because, like, then it's really obvious.
You just woke up to someone and you're like, hey, can you hear me?
And if you can respond, it's them.
Yeah, like, who's playing completely dumb here?
Snoopy, I think it might have picked your VR headset as a device or something.
You sound like you're in an empty room now.
Maybe it changed.
Maybe it changed, though.
I don't know why it says, like, maximum is one.
Because the literally trailer was like, you can get up to five followers.
I'm like, what?
You can apparently only have one follower for Kira.
Is that a one or a zero?
Let's see.
It's like 5v5.
It's like a... Okay, let's see.
Oh, I get the voting time.
I'm doing meeting time longer, too.
I know you would tell me if I sounded like shit.
What if I make us super fast?
I'm gonna make us super fast.
Yeah, because I put random.
I put random and it, like, makes it so that...
You sat in front of a camera writing, like, four names in your fucking notebook.
I know!
I didn't know what I was doing.
I was like, this game must be like, you know, I don't have a follower.
So I was like, kind of like...
You're just like, time to write everybody in.
I know, I just started writing down names like, fuck you, fuck you, fuck you.
Who am I missing, guys?
Who am I missing?
Who's missing?
Oh guys, it would be very awkward on the person that...
No, no, Trinaferce here.
Oh, Amelie!
Amelie!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
She has like, the weird name.
Have Mercy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, I just forgot she changed your name to the Have Mercy one.
Okay, oh yeah, I'll add more tasks, too.
Okay, how do I...
Alright.
For which one?
For Elle and Kira, right?
I think...
Yeah, just more things to do, I think.
Yeah, I'll add more.
I don't know if we wanna...
I don't know if it's worth reducing the amount of time in a day because it feels like most of the IDs can get stolen in one round, but I don't know.
Alright, I'll make it less than... I'll do 60 seconds instead of 90.
Okay.
Yeah, and then we'll see.
I made us super fast.
Oh, actually, no, I shouldn't.
Maybe I'll make us not super fast.
More time to talk, for sure.
Let's see.
Day, night, task.
I put 4 tasks.
I'll do 4 tasks.
And then...
I think that's good, right?
4 tasks.
Or should we have more?
2 was the default.
4 should be fine.
Alright, let's see what that's gonna be.
Alright.
Alright, start game.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I'm Kira.
Oh my gosh, this is it.
This is it.
This is what we've been training for.
This is exactly what we've been training for, guys.
Hey, guys.
Hey.
Where are you?
Are you okay?
Okay.
We'll never know.
Oh, wait.
I forgot I was proximity.
I forgot.
Wait.
Yeah, yeah.
I can hear you.
Vindicating evidence?
What does that do?
Judge collaborators and prevent role reviews?
Oh.
Whoops, I said out the thing.
I said out the stuff.
I didn't realize that was my task.
I didn't know.
I didn't know, guys.
Wait.
Wait, who's on me?
There's four people around me.
Who's around me right now?
Wait, what?
We're finding Kira, yeah.
Wait, I'm confused.
I'm confused.
Guys, I didn't know.
I didn't know.
Guys.
Oh.
Oh, I'm trying to...
I'm trying so hard to not fuck it up.
I'll assign a joint investigation.
Nice.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, what's going on?
Oh no.
Why is he so... How did someone get murdered already?
Oh my God!
Oh my God, she shot him!
Holy shit!
Guys!
Guys, gotta be careful.
You gotta put a safety on.
Holy shit.
That's so GG.
But they were working with Minto.
It was the Nerf gun.
I... I don't know what happened.
There was like 10 seconds left when we had this collaboration...
And I couldn't do anything.
Okay, so is it not Snuffy then?
Oh wait, Snuffy's dead.
What do you mean?
She literally got death noted.
We're like, so is it?
Is it not?
She can't be...
Is it... Could it be Snuffy?
Mine was stolen.
But we were all investigating that body.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Wait, why do we know it's not you guys?
Yeah, because my idea was stolen.
My idea was stolen when I was investigating.
And I was by myself first.
And then four people surrounded me.
So it was... I don't... I couldn't even see who the four was...
Because I was investigating that body first.
I know that I was in close contact with Grimmy a couple of times.
The people that I've been near are Bao and Grimmy, I think.
And also...
Wait, whose ID got stolen again?
My ID got stolen, because I was in that...
That body thing on the top left.
Okay, I was with Grimmy back during that.
And someone else.
So maybe Bao pretended to want...
Juniper.
...property.
But I did give you stuff back, though.
And I was giving a lost package back.
It's not my ID, though.
I've still lost that, so...
I swear I gave it.
Yeah, why did you give back her ID?
I don't think it's actually lost packages or not IDs.
It said... It said deliver package.
And I was trying to go around to deliver the one package back.
And I had the ID to give back, too.
Toki, why are you investigator investigating?
I'm just investigating.
You can change your name tag.
You can change your name tag in the customization.
Bao, where are you?
Yes?
Follow me.
I need to give you the notebook.
Okay.
Why are you... Why are you following us, huh?
Why are you following us?
What is she... What is she talking about?
I don't know.
She's being weird.
She thinks we're... She's in on it with us.
Yeah, she thinks she's... She thinks she's...
Wait, we don't... We shouldn't... We shouldn't be here.
There's a surveillance camera.
I didn't give you... I didn't give you the book.
I can't be... I can't be... I'm in too deep.
I'm in too deep.
We gotta find an area.
Wait,
what do I do as a joint?
Okay, you're Kira now.
Wait, what do I do as a invest... As a joint investigation?
Where's Amelie?
We need to work together!
Amelie, let's work together!
I'm here!
I'm doing it!
Oh my god!
Amelie died while I was trying to work together with her!
No!
She's in a better place now.
I know, yeah.
Kira looks so good.
Oh my god, I was doing a joint thing with Amelie and she just collapsed next to me.
I was like, Amelie, what's going on?
She stopped talking and then she just passed out.
Oh my gosh.
Come on, do your tasks, everybody.
There we go.
I mean, we're doing our tasks right now.
It's really hard to win by doing tasks.
So that means three died, right?
Because the last one was like, zero.
Well, I was with Amelie doing a joint investigation and then she collapsed.
Right next to you, huh?
Yeah, but it's not me.
I think there's a follower this round, too.
Because one of the little people that I investigated said that they saw someone passing off the notebook.
Like the little NPC.
Oh, wait, which side was it?
Do you remember?
Because we can open the map with M.
Was it in the beginning or the middle?
It was when it was daytime.
It was the one by the... It said in the classroom that they passed it off.
I think it's... I think it's maybe Bao or Juniper.
It is.
I mean, I can't really say anything to defend myself, but it's not me.
Puts hands up.
Puts hands up?
Wait, why do you think it's Bao or Juniper?
I get like really submissive.
I like lay on the ground, I roll over, I show my belly.
Okay, well, I'm gonna be on the floor.
That sounds like what a follower would say.
I think that's... I can't think of anything that involves me having to lie.
I pick investigator literally every time.
Let's go.
I got a dying message from Snuffy, but I don't really understand it.
So I think that was a confession, right?
Bao, like...
How is that a confession?
Confession!
You can read people's notebooks by... If you go into like the thing, it'll show you which ones they have marked off.
Oh god, there's 10 seconds, never mind.
It's Juniper!
I'm so sorry.
Wait, it's not Juniper.
Wait, it's not...
Yo, I'm chill.
Let me do it.
What does that mean?
Oh my gosh.
You're going downtown, Charlie Brown.
Yeah, you're going into Slammer.
Self-proclaimed standard investigator.
I can explain.
Bao, you killed too many people.
The moment I gave...
The moment I gave her the notebook, she killed everybody.
She never stopped.
You're supposed to stagger the kills!
She went fucking wild.
She was like...
I could've sworn that was the point of a book called The Death Note.
Oh my god.
I could be my favorite character.
Me too.
Oh, is it time?
Oh my god, we're all this ugliness.
New... Okay, wait.
New world.
What the hell is this version of Kira?
Why is there this version and this...
No, I'm Kira.
You're an investigator.
You're gonna be investigator, investigator.
I legitimately thought it was like only Kira's can like be...
I was like, wait a minute.
But I was like, oh no, I changed it.
There's so many more new characters now.
It's so exciting.
Oh yeah.
I don't remember this guy.
Misa is so cute.
That's Mellow.
That's how they... That's how they get you.
That's how they get you right there.
Oh my god.
I don't look sus.
Are you guys ready?
Yeah,
I read it out loud and I was like, oh my god.
And that's why I killed it off.
I was like, nobody noticed except for Snuffy.
So I was like, you're out.
You're out of the game.
I was like, and that's why I made Snuffy shoot herself.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They become Kira.
Yes.
So when I gave my notebook to Bao, she went fucking crazy.
She was like, it's time.
The collaboration things that happen with L aren't always the safe people.
No, no, no.
You don't know who's safe basically.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Or putting two people together and seeing what happens maybe.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
You see like if they get together and the other person died.
Alright, are you guys ready?
Yeah!
Oh no!
Every single time!
I like how we're learning more and more about this game.
The longer we play.
She's like, delete, delete, delete.
I'm gonna write your name and your name.
I'm not writing names by the way.
I'm not Kira.
I was just explaining something to my chat.
I had proximity points.
I'm not suspicious.
I swear.
You wanna get near me?
You wanna get near me, Kira?
You know what?
Yeah?
It'd be funny if I died right there.
That'd be so funny.
Let me open my...
Let me open my investigation thing right now.
Yeah?
Open your notebook right now.
Who's gonna...
I won't even have time to... I won't even have time to tell people.
Open your notebook.
Oh, okay.
Vindicating evidence.
Okay, we gotta...
It's this way.
We gotta get out of here.
Oh!
Okay.
Oh, so Grimmy's safe.
So she's safe.
Wait.
Avoid contact with others and keep the paper safe.
Okay.
Don't get near me, guys.
I need to get... Oh my god, there's so many NPCs.
I need to talk to...
Someone was talking on the receiver in the hotel.
Okay.
Wait, people were talking.
A lot of people were talking.
Oh my god, Grimmy got doxxed.
Oh shit, okay.
Wait, where is it?
Where's the dead body?
Is it over here?
It's over here.
Oh wait, but I need to talk to him first.
This is more important.
Oh wait.
Wait.
Okay.
Oh, you're safe.
Okay, I got you.
I got you, don't worry.
I know you're safe.
If your ID is stolen, it's not me.
Thank you.
Last round, my entire chat was going, don't suspect Oki.
She seems really chill in this round.
I was awesome.
Yeah, I mean, technically, I wasn't Kira.
Technically, I wasn't.
Oh my god, how many people am I supposed to talk to?
Holy shit, why is there so... Why are there so many suspicious people?
Oh, Juniper!
What's on her notebook?
Nobody!
Juniper, you gotta be taking notes.
What kind of detective are you?
Juniper died here, by the way.
May I judge you, please?
Okay.
No!
Oh my god!
Jesus!
Holy shit!
Eyes wide open.
No, she knew too much!
She looked up!
Who found her notebook?
I have her notebook, but she had nothing in it.
She was not doing her homework.
And literally, I was like, I looked in it, and like, nothing.
I'll be honest, I don't ever do my homework.
Are you supposed to... Wait.
You're supposed to put...
You're supposed to put notes on who you think is like, most suspicious.
Yeah, yeah, so you click on them.
There's like, oh, this is the last person.
I still have my ID.
ID.
Why do we think F is Kira?
Yeah, yeah, they can help.
On the bottom portion of the map, someone was seen at night...
Holding a notebook and opening it.
I...
Wait, is it longer?
I think so!
Wait, yeah.
Yeah, I think I actually made it longer now.
I think...
Uh-huh.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Also, so Vienna, why do you think it's Snuffy?
And now she's dead.
She said it was Snuffy, because...
Alright, you know what?
Let's do it.
Let's take a shot.
Guys, let's take a shot.
If we're wrong...
Yeah, that seems like a confession right there.
Let's do it.
Again?!
She literally...
Are you...
Do you have any IDs on you?
Oh!
Okay, so she wasn't Kira.
So she wasn't...
Let's see... I had to deliver something.
What did I deliver?
Oh.
I have an item for you!
Wait, not that!
I gave you Juniper's notebook, Mint.
Mint, get over here!
I have something for... Mint, get over here!
I literally have a task for you!
Wait, actually, I don't.
JK.
I had to find the lost item.
It is weird that she's not talking back to me.
And that's pretty sus.
Hmm.
Okay.
It's pretty weird.
Alright, there it is.
Okay.
Mint was next to me, so if my ID is gone, then...
Then we all know why.
Yeah, why Mint no talk?
Hmm?
Why she no talk to me?
Someone wrote during the day...
Oh, somebody's dead!
Someone wrote during the day near the cafe class.
Where's cafe?
So, it was here.
That they wrote the notebook.
Hmm.
Yeah?
What are you doing?
What are you doing over there?
You're not saying anything.
Okay.
You're not talking.
Why aren't you talking, Mint?
Why are you just staring at me?
Huh?
Fucking freak.
I swear, if I die, if I die right here, I swear to God.
Oh?
Who is it?
This is so funny.
I love to speak death and like just harassing the person I'm talking to.
Oh!
Oh my God!
Live and bow!
Okay, I'm just wondering this time for sure, you guys can hear me now, right?
Yeah.
So, new update on this, I can't hear anybody, but I can actually hear all the people who are dead.
So, but they can't hear me.
Wait, Doki, were you talking to me?
Yeah, yeah, I think the mic bugged out too.
Yes, I can hear you!
I found Limu's dead body and her notebook had Mint only circled.
I can perform a seance with the dead.
Guys, just listen to me.
What do the dead say, Snuffy?
What are they telling you?
Guys, who killed you?
Let me know.
Let them speak through you, Snuffy.
That's so funny.
Is that why you weren't saying anything when I was talking to you?
Yeah, I kept trying to be like Amelie.
You couldn't say, I couldn't hear you.
I thought you were just being funny and flipping the deck.
What is Fow, Limu and Juniper saying?
What were Juniper's final words?
He asked her why she was like, it's Snuffy in the end.
I like how Snuffy is legend, legend.
FBI, FBI.
Open up, FBI, FBI.
That's me.
Sorry, Mint, but in the beginning, I was next to you and my ID card was stolen.
And then now, Limehunter name circled, so it makes me think it's you.
I was investigating you.
Oh, you know what?
It was just to investigate you.
That's suspicious.
Here's the thing.
When I talked to an NPC like last round, who was like, oh, yeah.
Well, in this area, someone was seen at night opening a book.
It had just turned to nighttime like 20 seconds before and only Mint was in that area.
I'd like to read a good book.
But it could have been you too.
What do you mean by that?
I wouldn't have talked to that guy if it was me.
He's gonna die tomorrow.
You could be making that up.
I know.
I talked to him.
Oh, look at her.
She's stumbling.
She's panicking just like Kira would.
I actually can't tell who's dead and who's alive.
So if I'm responding to people you can't even hear, I'm so sorry.
What do they have to say about Mint?
I don't know why I'm just farting.
I'm innocent!
Why am I innocent?
You literally said long live Kira!
I mean, I'm a follower.
I should have given the notebook to you, Snuffy.
You got dead.
I'm inexperienced.
Don't blame me.
Can't believe the person whose name... Whose shirt is literally saying Kira was Kira.
Oh my God, you're making Death Note 2 on Netflix?
Yeah.
My guy locked up forever.
You're looking a little goofy.
It's always the one you least suspect.
Her final message.
Mint.
I wonder what a circle around Mint's name could mean.
I'm sorry, Mint.
Vaibhav was actually playing the game.
Circle people's names?
Yeah, that's what the notebook is for.
You can like circle...
To be fair, I've been Kira like 99% of the time.
Wait a minute.
Oh, well, this is awkward.
Oh my God, we have so many chefs here!
Too many chefs.
Too many cooks.
We're all getting the same stuff at the same time, so everyone ends up wearing the same shit.
That's not true.
I picked a bow instead.
That's right.
I'm trying to make myself look atrocious.
I wanted to look cute.
I'm adorable.
I like how Snuffy is the only one that took the shower cap.
She's...
Nobody else.
Oh!
So I have to use it.
Alright, alright, you guys ready?
Wait, what do you want to change in the rules?
You know on like Gaia Online when people were fangirling over L?
This is how they drew him.
Just with a cute little bow and pretty glasses.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah!
You don't even have the roundness I do!
So cute!
Baby girl L!
Welcoming a brand new girl.
Let's see...
A mellow or a matte fan?
Alright, I'm upping the multiplier.
Which one?
What was your favorite fella?
Mosquito.
Mosquito?
Oh no.
Alright, I made it so that tasks go by faster now.
So it puts more percentage.
Alright, let's see if it does work though.
It definitely won't for me.
Good luck everybody.
Oh no.
I gotta make sure...
Approximity chat's not on.
I gotta make sure guys.
Hey!
Cappy.
Oh, you like it?
You think it's pretty?
Yeah?
Yeah!
It's Louis Vuitton!
I'm looking.
Oh, you're investigating!
Gotta make sure guys I'm not using my voice chat.
I gotta make sure.
Kira.
Are you there Kira?
Oh.
What you doing?
Huh?
Are you...
Singing a little song?
Whoa!
There's a camera in that area.
Oh.
Time to resolve.
Okay.
I'm resolving.
I'm doing my job.
I'm a good person.
You have...
Do you have any IDs on you?
Guys, I don't think Amelie knows about the...
I don't think Amelie knows about the...
Transmitter guys.
I don't think she knows about the transmitter.
I'm trying to...
I'm trying to tell her about the transmitter.
No!
Amelie, Amelie, Amelie, Amelie, Amelie, Amelie.
Follow me, follow me, follow me Amelie.
Bye Amelie.
Kill them.
You know you want to.
Yeah, me too.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
What are you trying to do?
What are you...
Oh!
What are you trying to do?
Snuffy, are you trying to steal my ID?
Are you trying to steal my ID, Snuffy?
Oh wait, I forgot you can't...
You can't talk right now.
No!
Don't post my name!
Because she's so powerful.
Oh my god.
Dude, this happens to her every game.
If she's not the first to like be a killer, she's the first to die.
I like how...
I like how like she's always ran over by a truck too.
It's always a truck.
That's the third time she's been hit by a truck.
There's like...
There's like other choices.
There was gun, chandelier, all that shit, but they picked the truck.
That's just the signature.
Limu, what did she say?
What is she saying?
What is Limu saying?
You're impressing Goosetalker!
Because like I was Kira before.
Yeah, but you literally made me shoot myself.
I literally made...
I literally made Selfie like shoot herself with a Nerf gun.
You mentioned all the choices that you could pick.
Yeah, because I was looking.
I was like thinking like, what do I make them do?
Doki got really close to me and then did nothing about it and just turned around and like didn't go anywhere and she just wanted to get really close to me.
That was kind of...
What do you mean?
I was doing the fucking investigating body thing.
I got my ID stolen though from that pile.
Wait, who said that?
What?
No, no.
I killed two people.
No, I killed Snuffy and someone else and then I gave the book to somebody else.
Alright, call me as Kira.
You're gonna be so surprised when it's not me.
Yeah, waste that.
Do it.
Vote for me right now.
Get me arrested right now.
Do it.
Arrest me.
Arrest... Yeah, do it.
Come on.
I wanna be handcuffed to somebody.
Do it.
I wanna be handcuffed.
Yeah.
Do it.
What if it's my kink?
What if it's what I'm into?
Do it.
Put me in handcuffs.
Come on.
Someone handcuff me to somebody.
If I lost my ID too, I was investigating that one body by myself.
I think someone applied a little funny thing when you vote someone else.
That's right.
Who am I attached to?
Am I attached to Snuffy?
Yeah, that's right.
What if I'm into that Snuffy?
That's right.
Yeah.
Okay, wait.
Wait a minute.
Okay, now you can start barking for me.
Oh, look at that!
Nothing!
Look at that!
That's right, and now I get to be attached to you.
No.
I'm gone.
If I were Kira, you'd be dead!
That's fucking right.
If I was Kira, you'd be dead by now.
I will be the god of the new world!
Joke's on you guys.
I like this.
I'm just standing here.
I got a lost item.
I did it.
I did my task.
Wait, it's what?
What happened?
Five people resolving?
Okay.
Well, that's a lot of resolvers.
A lot of resolvers.
Oh gosh, all of us are in here.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, what's going on?
A lot of people.
Wait, how do you know it's Amelie?
Wait, what?
Because all she did was...
Limu was only in contact with Bao and Amelie.
And Amelie is so sus.
What?
I'm not hopeless.
I'll keep watch.
I have something to give you.
Snuffy.
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
Amelie, I can't do anything.
I can't do anything.
You die.
It's on you.
I can't do it.
I can't.
Who is L?
I don't know.
Goodbye.
Sorry, Grimmie, I tried to spread your nostrils.
His nostrils.
So easy.
Let's go.
That's right.
Okay, but I was right about Doki.
I was right about Doki.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I gave away my IDs before.
She passed off the book.
No, I didn't.
Amelie was actually the cure-all.
I was just giving her all the IDs.
But I had no IDs, so I could live.
This is actually more fun when you kind of get the idea of the game.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Can we play another one?
I'm gonna try.
I tried doing that before.
It didn't work, so I don't know.
Was it the sound settings thing?
No, because I can still hear everybody.
Right now, I can hear everybody.
It's literally only when the game plays.
That's so weird.
And I can hear Limes, but she can't hear me and she's also dead and I'm not.
It's so weird.
It's like day one bug, maybe.
Alright, let's see.
Oh my God, there's just as planned for customization.
As long as Snuffy can still hear me, I'm gonna like...
Annoy the shit out of her every time I die, I guess.
She's like the seance.
We're ready to...
We're like...
Lime, what is Lime saying?
Snuffy, tell us her final words.
What is it?
Are we all here?
Wait, we're missing one person.
Did Snuffy leave?
Oh yeah, Snuffy's trying to fix it.
Snuffy's trying to fix it.
We're slowly understanding the game now.
I hope they have different maps in the future.
Yeah, and like different tasks to do rather than just talk to people.
Yeah, yeah.
To be fair, this game came out so fucking fast.
So I feel like they're like...
Got dropping now.
For what reason?
It needs a little bit of like cleaning up, but...
I like the ideas of it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's another alternative.
Little among us, definite alternative.
It makes you think and like...
Suspect people in different ways because of the textbooks and stuff.
Yeah, then you gotta like...
Look everywhere, you're like...
Why are you so close to me?
Huh?
Every little thing makes you...
Yeah, yeah.
I also like the music.
I think the music is good.
Yeah, she was like...
It's like...
Supposed to practice COVID protocols here.
Why are you guys all so close?
Guys, guys.
Only one person here is wearing a mask, right?
Two people are wearing masks.
What's wrong with you guys?
I'm spreading my germs in all directions.
I'm literally...
Yeah, I'm literally sneezing right now.
I wonder who gave it.
Alright, Snuffy, can you hear us?
Yes.
Okay.
Alright, I'm starting the game.
We'll have to see in the game.
If someone's next to Snuffy, confirm.
Okay, hoping for you.
Investigating.
Can't wait to write some names on the notebook.
Wait, what do you mean?
Oh my God, I can't wait to write some names.
I'm so excited to write names on that notebook.
Whoa!
Hey.
Look, we can work together.
Bow, we can work together.
Bow, bow, bow, bow, bow, bow.
We can...
Bow, bow, we can work together.
Bow, we can...
Hahaha.
Just as planned.
Alright.
Someone may have stolen my ID.
Who stole my ID?
Silly me, nobody can steal my ID.
Okay, we gotta get...
Whoa, whoa.
Hello.
Whoa.
Why are you guys all so close to me?
Whoa, hey Snuffy.
You hear me, Snuffy?
Okay, I completed all my tasks.
Oh?
Monitor.
Let's see, I need a...
Death note test.
Oh, okay, back down I go.
Whoa.
Don't worry, I got you guys.
I'm guarding, I'm guarding all of you.
Making sure everybody is okay.
Mika, why aren't you doing it?
Why are you close to them?
Why are you guarding them so close up?
That's a weird way to guard bodies, that's all I'm saying.
Alright guys, I don't think we can...
No, we were all at the bottom, right?
We were being a little bit too frisky.
We were way too close to each other.
Talking to a transmitter during the night?
It literally just turned into night.
Huh, that's... yeah, Giga is mega sus.
During the day?
Wait, that doesn't...
What?
Everybody, I spam that transmitter all the time.
Oh, who do I have to do this to?
Oh, monitor.
Juniper!
Oh?
Make a contact with collaborator to publicly reveal?
How do we publicly reveal?
Oh, okay, Amelie is safe.
Amelie is safe.
Was suspicious, but she's actually clear now.
I'm actually clean!
What?
Someone in my chat literally just said, Amelie sus.
Well, Amelie just gets a pass now.
It just says she was an investigator.
I trust that.
She's not sus?
You're dumb!
Nothing happened.
Nobody's dead.
Yeah, that's weird that nobody did anything.
Who hasn't got Kira yet?
Whoa!
And who do you...
Oh, my ID was stolen, but...
I think it's Bao.
My ID was stolen, mine was.
And what is your last investigation?
Hmm...
Yeah, and I was next to Bao and...
You were whacking off?
You were next to the body whacking off?
And how would you know that, investigator?
How would you know that?
Only a Kira follower could watch.
Limo?
She is awfully quiet.
Limo is alive, it has to be her.
You're right, Limo.
It's a little suspicious that you're still alive.
A little weird, a little wacky.
I think...
Are you...
Tell me, are you...
I have no idea anyway, are you...
Are you a Kira follower?
Are you a follower?
Are you Kira?
There's nobody here, there's nobody here but you and me.
Just bring out your... I promise, bring out your notebook.
I won't tell, I promise, I won't tell.
Kira to Kira.
Kira to Kira!
Bring your notebook out right now!
God is really on my side.
Oh shit, oh...
Oh fuck, I'm okay!
I'm okay, I lived!
We got...
We got hit by a car, but we're okay, we're okay.
Yeah, we were shoved in.
It happened to me in the tutorial, yeah.
Okay, three people resolving, where is everybody else?
Oh, that means one of us is not resolving the other thing.
I was resolving.
Oh, someone is not...
We're resolving, we're resolving.
No, it just pushes you.
It prevents the new god from... like the new world order.
Who just said I'm Kira?
Who was that?
Somebody in the file said I'm Kira.
Oh shit, I'm alive!
I'm alive!
No, I wasn't, what the fuck?
I was investigating.
No, no, no, I would never.
I mean, I'm literally wearing a shirt.
Yeah, typical Kira.
Typical Kira, thinking it's me.
Oh, who could be Kira?
Wait.
Wait, what?
Wait, what was that?
Juniper?
I think...
That's weird.
Okay, where the fuck are the other cameras?
What was that?
Oh.
Okay, nice.
Someone wrote something during...
Oh, no!
No!
No, it wasn't Juniper!
Who was it?
No!
How do you... be angrily again?
I didn't find Amelie's final words.
What?
I can't complete my investigation.
I don't even know.
What do you mean?
I wasn't close enough.
I did my...
Oh, wait.
Who was it?
It was Belle.
Wait, who was it?
Was it Belle?
Her internet might have gone out again.
It might have, yeah.
That was a really good game so far though.
I was eating that shit up.
That was drama.
That was like drama, oh my god.
So, who was the killer?
Yeah, who was it?
It was me and Limu.
Oh, Giga.
Giga!
What happened?
I went to tell Doki that I thought it was Giga and she got hit by the car in front of me.
No!
I feel so bad.
Oh, if they found DC, I wouldn't use the bathroom.
What happened?
Wait, who was Akira?
Who was Akira?
It was me and Limu.
Oh...
Okay, I didn't know you, but...
I knew it was Limu because she was alive.
She was alive.
She was like, do you think everybody is being a little too accusatory?
Like,
yeah, I trust you.
First mistake.
If Limu lives past first round, we know.
Alright, starting.
Let's go.
Oh my god, when can I be L?
When can I be L?
I wanna be L.
I wanna be a cool... Oh my god.
I trust you.
If something happens, I know where... Oh, you can't cancel the take ID, by the way.
No, that's not true.
That's not true.
Woah!
Okay, I don't trust you.
I don't want... I don't trust you, too.
Oh, woah, woah, woah.
My ID is gone.
I know what happened.
I don't trust all of you.
I have one person to trust.
Okay.
Woah, woah, woah.
Why did Bao get near me?
Alright guys, if I die, we know why.
If I die, we know what happened.
No, don't get near me!
Don't get near me!
I'm protecting documents!
I need to protect these papers!
Okay, I have three people that I'm a little suspicious now.
I feel like... Okay, if my ID is gone, then it's...
It has to be... Oh, okay.
Everybody uses a transmitter, so...
It has to be these three.
My ID is gone.
Communicating evidence?
Oh my god, I need them to know I'm okay.
I need them to know!
No, no, no!
It's me!
Me!
No!
I wanted to be innocent!
Okay, Juniper is innocent.
Juniper, all I'm saying is that it can't be me.
Juniper, it can't be me.
It can't be me.
Yeah, what are the odds?
But I am a little suspicious of other people, though.
Let's hold hands, because it's not me.
Just put all of them suspicious, and then you just start marking people who you think it's not.
Oh my god, we did so much.
Did Kira do anything?
Oh, Kira was a little confused.
It's okay.
It's not me!
Yeah, if I was Kira, I would've killed people.
Yeah, but you could've recited an innocent person's line.
Yeah.
I was with you in the beginning of one of the rounds, and you didn't say it.
You didn't say it when I was with you last time.
Like what?
I would never.
Yeah, in my journal, in my investigation notepad.
I have an investigation notepad like all of you guys.
This is a lot of accusations for literally nothing happening.
I'm just going to say that.
Yeah, I'm going to skip.
Oh!
Yeah, I just...
Yeah,
I was... yeah.
Juniper's ID...
I can't go off of IDs because I'm usually touching like 8 people.
Whoever is checked on your investigation pad as like an exclamation point is somebody you were that close to.
And it's usually like 5 out of 8 people.
Right, right.
I still have my ID and I was next to Juniper.
And Juniper still has her ID, so we're fine.
Yeah, we were next to each other.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
See?
I didn't take your ID.
I told you.
Oh yeah, you like it?
Yeah, I like it.
I can keep being sick for you.
Woah!
Woah, get away, get away!
Oh, you guys are awfully close to each other.
Oh, I'm heading over.
I'm heading over to the furthest one.
Don't worry, I got you.
I'm literally resolving right now.
I literally just got here.
No, it's just me.
No, there's only two people resolving, so Giga, why aren't you resolving?
Press it, Giga!
Press it!
No, you weren't.
I didn't see it.
Alright, now I know if my ID is gone, now I know.
I'm taking notes right now.
Yeah, I think it might be Giga right there.
Wait, someone who's in the classroom.
Wait.
The restroom?
Where's the restroom?
I'm trying my best, Elle!
I don't know where the bathroom is!
Where's the bathroom?
Top left?
Okay.
Don't worry.
Why didn't you...
Bow.
Why didn't you... Bow.
Why didn't you...
Bow.
Why didn't you... Bow.
Okay.
Alright.
The last person she was with was you, Bow.
Yeah, but you could be a follower.
You were going through some stuff.
You were like...
Oh!
How is she here?
Put your notebook out right now.
You can put your notebook out right now.
It's over, dude.
It's so over.
Oh my God.
A heart?
Oh!
Goodbye.
Another heart attack.
Oh, Juniper died too.
She was just... She was just innocent!
You should protect the people who get labeled as such.
They're obviously gonna be targeted.
Guys, I think...
I think Bow could either be a follower... I think it's Bow.
I... I... I think it's...
Oh yeah, why am I dead?
Why were you just... You were like...
Hmm, look at these...
Bow was looking through this person's documents?
Because you could be the follower.
You could be a follower.
You could be a sheep.
Her last message was that also my ID has been stolen, but...
I wrote down who was close to me.
And...
Bow, Mint, and Giga were close to me.
Hey, hey, my ID got stolen and the only one I went close enough to this round was Giga.
Because I gave her a thing.
Oh!
She gave me a present.
She gave me a gift.
Alright, Giga, defend yourself.
I gave you a gift, but my ID got stolen and nobody else has been close enough to me.
Yeah.
Bow, why don't you defend your Kira, Bow?
Bow, do you think it's Giga, Bow?
I think Snuffy's the follower, baby.
Sorry, Snuffy.
I think the only person I trust is Snuffy.
I know Amelie's dying message was Bow.
Giga might not actually be...
Yeah, Giga might not actually be Kira because I also saw a witness say that an ID got, like, handed off.
But I think Giga's involved either way.
But also, Giga didn't help us with the body.
That's true.
Oh my God.
And Giga was honest while we were doing the body together.
I didn't click on it, because every time we stack up, like, everyone's ID gets stolen, so I've been stepping back.
Yeah, I've been using, like, one or two to do it.
Yeah, but my ID's gone.
That was the only time I was super close to people.
That's pretty suspect.
Yeah, that's the only time I'm really scared of physical touch.
Bye.
I mean, I think it's enough votes already.
I don't think you need to overcook.
With two people dead, we should vote anyway.
Yeah.
True.
What does it mean to, like, does it matter who we pick to confiscate items?
Yes, it does, because if you pick...
They can get them back.
Yeah, if you pick a Kira follower, they can get it back, basically.
Wait, then why did you pick Bao?
What if Bao is a follower?
I'm not!
I just dropped... Who is the follower?
Very interesting.
We did it.
I actually wasn't Kira originally.
I was the follower, and then, like, right before the round ended...
I was so scared of it.
I literally killed somebody right before Limeu saw me, and so I thought...
Like, Doki saw me so easily one time, so I thought Limeu would've just instantly seen me and been like, Oh, shit, I just saw her kill somebody, so I was like, uh, you can take this.
You are so suspicious.
That's so funny!
That's no good.
I can't believe it wasn't you, Bao.
I'm so sorry.
I can't believe it wasn't her.
Wait,
Bao, you were L?
You were L?
Oh my God, wait.
That's LG, LG.
That was fun!
Thank you, everybody!
Thank you all for coming!
You guys had fun playing Death Note!
GG's, everybody!
GG!
Bye-bye!
I like that this game has in-voice chat.
It helps a lot.
I want to do things where I can just make the game all about me.
No, sorry, I'm not gonna do that again.
You were so good.
You were a natural detective.
Oh, thank you!
I want to get L sometime.
That was really fun.
Me too!
Yeah, I want to get L, too.
I want to know what that was like.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, thank you, guys.
Yeah, GG's!
GG's!
Bye-bye, Snuffy!
Bye, Mint!
I'm destroying the room now.
Oh, yeah!
That was really fun.
I'm glad we tried out this game on launch day.
Obviously, there's a lot of stuff that they can improve on.
Like, because it just got launched.
So, obviously, there's so many small things they could do to make it...
to make it a bit more interesting and stuff.
But I do enjoy the premise for a game that launched out of nowhere.
With no warning.
I think, like, the more you play it, the more you can, like, you know, trick people.
And the more intricate you can be with the whole setting.
But there's definitely a lot of potential for, like, Death Note SD.
I love, like, I love the cosmetics.
I love the cosmetics and, like, the different stuff you can do with, like, the names and stuff.
And the in-game...
I think the in-game voice chat was really nice.
I think they just need to fix the...
They definitely needed to fix the in-game VC a bit more.
Because it was a little finicky.
But I had a great time!
We had a great time.
I hope that you guys enjoyed watching.
It was very hard organizing this collab.
Because it was, like, you know, the game came out, like...
The news for this game came out super last minute.
And, like, I was like, oh my god, wait.
Time to fucking grab people!
I messaged so many different people to see if they were, like, free and stuff.
So it was, like, just scrambling around trying to grab people to play the game on launch.
Yeah.
And I had a great time.
It was great.
Hey, guys.
I am going to call it here.
I've been coughing a lot.
So I'm going to rest my voice now.
I had a very long day with dance classes, Apex, then collab.
So I'm going to rest up here.
Thank you, everybody, for coming.
I really do appreciate it.
I hope you guys had a fun time watching.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you didn't stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'm going to buy some cough drops after this.
Hey, guys.
Bye, everybody.
Bye!